the continuing negotiations on the
pandemical court and amendments to the
international Health regulations are
unprecedented opportunity for us all to
learn from the successes and failures of
the response to the covid-19 pandemic
there are several key points words
repeating to avoid misconceptions
first
this Accord is a generational
opportunity that we must cease
we are the generation that lived through
the covid-19 pandemic so we must be the
generation that learns the lessons he
taught us and makes the changes to keep
future Generations safer
second
the two processes are negotiated by
member states four member states and
will if enacted be implemented in member
states in accordance with their own
National laws
third all member states will retain
their own sovereignty to set their own
domestic Health policies
foreign
or the amended International Health
regulations will seed sovereignty to who
is simply bogus and as I said it many
times fake news
who will not gain any power to override
domestic policy decisions
nor would we want to
I know the journalists listening to this
briefing are largely health and science
journalists who have a deeper
understanding of health and understand
how an accord can help bolster our
Collective pandemic defenses
so I ask you to keep following the facts
about these two processes to dispel myth
and to inform your colleagues on the
news and editorial desks so there is
accurate reporting
this processes represent the serious
commitment from all 194 who member
states towards their populations
and we cannot let Miss and this
information
jeopardize them